في خطوه غير مسبوقه
بوتينغ في مركب واحد والخوف الامريكي
يتصدر المشهد روسيا تنزل وحشا جديدا الى
احشاء المحيط وبعد صاروخ الشيطان موسكو
تدخل سلاحا اخر لحسم المعارك في اوكرانيا
تعلنها السلام مع روسيا يمر عبر هذه
الساحه ولا شيء اخر والدفاع الروسيه تعلن
عن خسائر الاوكران الفادعه في الهجوم
المضاد وواشنطن ترد والكرملين يضع شرطين
اساسيين لانهاء معارك البطون الخاويه
واردوغان يناقش الامر مع الامم المتحده
وهديه الروسيه القطريه ثمينه لست دول
افريقيه التنين الصيني يتحضر لانهاء
الهيمنه الامريكيه في العالم وفرنسا ترضخ
للانقلابيين في النيجر
رهب امريكي
العقوب لم تنفع وعادت بطريقه عكسيه على
الغرب عموما وعلى الولايات المتحده خصوصا
بوتين يتقدم بخطوات واثقه لكن الخطوه
القادمه هي ما يحير الامريكان اكثر حيث
اعلن البيت الابيض ان الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي
مفاوضات للاسلحه بين روسيا وكوريا
الشماليه لامداد موسكو باسلحه كوريه
شماليه لاستخدامها في حربها ضد اوكرانيا
وبالتزامن مع ذلك ذكرت صحيفه
تدفع باتجاه خطوه غير مسبوقه في جيش كوريا
الشماليه وحسب الصحيفه اقترحت موسكو ان
تنضم كوريا الشماليه الى مناورات بحريه
تجمع بين روسيا والصين لتكون اول مشاركه
من نوعها بالنسبه لبيونج يانج يبدو ان
بوتين قرار الرد على الدعم الغربي الذي لا
ينقطع عن اوكرانيا وكما يقولها اليمانيون
الحجر من القاع والدم من راس الجبيلي
اي ان موسكو لن تخسر شيئا باضافه كام الى
صفها في الحرب وامريكا هي من ستتلقى
الخسائر لننتقل الى الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث
تتحضر روسيا للفتره القادمه بطريقه مختلفه
هذه المره وذلك بالنزول الى احشاء البحار
والمحيطات بوحش كاسر باعلان وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن نجاح الاختبارات الجديده على
احدث غواصه في سلسله غواصات
الملقبه بالثقب الاسود
لاختفائها الطويل والعميق في مياه
المحيطات وتمكنت من الوصول الى عمق يصل
الى 190 مترا تحت سطح الماء في بحر
البلطيق والرساله واضحه للاوكرانيين
ولحلفائهم الغربيين وهنا توجه موسكو رساله
اخرى لا تقل قوه عن سابقتها فبعد الاعلان
عن ادخال صواريخ سرمت الى الخدمه اكد وزير
الدفاع الروسي ان اربعه قاذفات استراتيجيه
من طراز 160 ان ستدخل الخدمه في القوات
المسلحه الروسيه هذا العام وفق ما نقلت
عنه وسائل اعلام روسيه والقاذفه
الاستراتيجيه طائره كبيره الحجم مخصصه
لاسقاط الكميات هائله من القنابل
والصواريخ بما يفوق قدرات المقاتله
الحربيه الصغيره لضرب اهداف استراتيجيه
لدى القوات المعاديه مثل القواعد العسكريه
ولديها القدره ايضا على حمل اسلحه دمار
شامل فهل حان وقت حسم الحرب الاوكرانيه
الاجابه تاتي من اوكرانيا بان كل تلك
الاسلحه لا تخف حكومه كياف حيث صرح وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمتري كوليبا بان
الطريق الى الدبلوماسيه مع روسيا
الاتحاديه يمر عبر ساحه المعركه مشيرا الى
انه لا توجد دوله في العالم تريد احلال
السلام بقدر بلاده برايكم هل تريدك يافا
السلام حقا لا يبدو ذلك فها هو يقوم برحله
عمل الى مقاطعه ليزور مراكز قياده
التشكيلات العسكريه التابعه لقوتك في
الجزء الخاضع الى السيطره الاوكرانيه
وليسلم مقاتليه عددا من الاوسمه في
الميدان ايضا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تدمير مسيره اوكرانيه في القرم بينما اعلن
رئيس بلديه موسكو ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه دمرت ثلاثه مسيرات كانت تحلق
باتجاه العاصمه الروسيه وقال المسؤول
الروسي ان اضرارا لحقت بمنطقه
سقوط احدى المسيرات لتعود الدفاع الروسي
وتؤكد ان قوتها قامت بتعزيز مواقعها على
محور الزابوريج وحيدت اكثر من 655 عسكريا
واسقطت مروحيه في مختلف المناطق خلال 24
ساعه واليكم المصدر هنا وزير الدفاع
الروسي
يعلن ان قوتك يافا تكبدت خسائر فادحه منذ
بدايه ما يسمى بالهجوم المضاد تجاوزت 66
الف عسكري وسبعه الاف قطعه سلاح واضاف ان
القوات الروسيه اسقطت خلال الشهر الاخير
اكثر من الف مسيره اطلقتها قوه كياف
والعهده على المصدر كما نتصفحه امامكم في
موقع وكاله العالميه من جهتها بدات القوات
الاوكرانيه تفصيل اقفاص وهياكل ضخمه
لحمايه المدرعات والدبابات والمدافع غربيه
الصنع من مسيره اللانسات الروسيه التي
دمرت مئه الدبابات والمدافع الغربيه لقوات
كياث هذا واعلن مسؤول امريكي كبير ان
الهجوم المضاد الذي شنته اوكرانيا في
الجنوب حقق تقدما ملحوظا خلال 72 ساعه
وذكرت صحيفه الجارديان ان المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
قال ان اوكرانيا حققت بعض النجاح في
التعامل مع خط الدفاع الثاني لروسيا في
الوقت الذي اظهرت صور الاقمار الصناعيه
على مدى اشهر قيام الروس
اسنان التنين في الاراضي التي يسيطرون
عليها في اوكرانيا وها هو المصدر يتحدث
اعلنت اوكرانيا اخيرا نجاحها اختراق
القوات الدفاعيه الرئيسيه لروسيا في
الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه وضعت روسيا خطه
تحصينات ضخمه عبر بناء خنادق مضاده
للدبابات وحواجز خرسانيه تسمى اسنان
التنين لن
نتقل الان فيما يتعلق بصفقه الحبوب الاول
يتمثل بربط البنك الزراعي الروسي بنظام
سويت والثاني تامين سفن الشحن واضاف
اردوغان انه يعتزم بحث مساله استئناف صفقه
الحبوب مع الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوترش خلال اجتماعات الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده في نيويورك وهناك
اكد بوتين ان العمل جاري على توريد مليون
طن من الحبوب الى تركيا بمساعده قطريه
لدعم الدول الاكثر فقرا وقال نحن على وشك
ابرام اتفاقيه مع ست دول افريقيه حيث
نعتزم توفير الغذاء مجانا
الخدمات اللوجستيه مجانا لتسليم هذه
الشحنه المفاوضات تقترب من الاكتمال
تقريبا وستبدا عمليات التسليم خلال
الاسبوعين المقبلين يبدو ان
الحظ ست دول افريقيه عن طريق بوتين فماذا
عن بقيه الدول ايها الغربيون
الاحداث والتطورات كشفت تقارير الغربيه
وامريكيه ان الصين تتطلع لتدشين قواعد
عسكريه بحريه في عده دول لا سيما في اسيا
وافريقيا بعد ان باتت تمتلك اكبر قوه
بحريه في العالم وترى هذه التقارير ان
تسعى لتعزيز نفوذها العسكري رغما في
الصيني لهذه التقارير بعد اغلاقه لنحو شهر
وعلى طريقه الجافا فتح المجلس العسكري في
النيجر المجال الجوي امام الرحلات المدنيه
والتجاريه بالاضافه الى الحدود البريه مع
مالي وتشاد وبوركينا فاسو والجزائر في
الوقت نفسه استمرت المظاهرات والاعتصامات
امام القاعده العسكريه الفرنسيه في
العاصمه نيامي مطالبه برحيل القوات
الفرنسيه من جهه اخرى قالت صحيفه لوموند
الفرنسيه ان باريس بدات مناقشات مع المج
العسكريه في شان سحب بعض قواتها هناك
واضافت الصحيفه ان فرنسا تخطط لارسال جزء
من قواتها الموجوده في النيجر الى تشاد وك
انت بقائد الدبلوماسي والعسكري في النيجر
حيث تحافظ هناك على وجود الف وخمسمائه
جندي
[موسيقى]